so I believe in entrepreneurs and
today's show it's all about over
delivering like crazy to your customers
and I want to check with store there's a
guy who offered to work for me named
Jill Marc and I put out a request that I
needed a marketing assistant to help me
with my business and I have a unusual
hiring process but I'd ended up hiring
ten people because I like giving people
a shot I give people a shot and see how
they do because I find performance is
way better than than just hiring off of
a resume so I hired these ten people and
I give them five hours to do a job
maximum and what I love doing is seen
you look at it and you see how
successful they are doing do they look
you for the full five hours are they
doing the job on time the good
communication skill and this one guy Joe
Mar and I almost didn't hire him on but
I did I mean it up being the best guy
what he did was he told me you know he
did it in less than five hours
attachment maybe three hours and he
looked at everybody else's work because
it was all shared and started correcting
their mistake clean where they were
making errors and so when I came down to
who am I gonna hire I went with Joe Mar
cuz the guy was over delivering my crazy
right he didn't just do what I asked him
to do he did it in a faster time and
then he went above and beyond by fixing
the errors and so it was easy for me to
give him the full-time jobs this is what
you want to do you've got to go beyond
what they're just asking you to do doing
the bare basics is not enough you need
to go way above and beyond to wow them
and get them to say yes okay I want to
get to the call I have Tim's on the line
how can I help good morning Evan all I
have a guest kind of a twist on it I can
over deliver my product but it's
penetration of the market and it's a
really vital service and that's my
dilemma and I was looking at possibly
funding through Kickstarter
okay what's your company here's the deal
I'm a retired firefighter paramedic and
I'm also recovering alcohol that
attempted suicide well as a firefighter
the problem is skyrocketing and
firefighters in America that they are
killing themselves committing suicide
and I know how
off with the correct treatment to
firefighters to to get them to help and
get them the resources that they need
but it's a it's a cultural thing
firefighters you know it's a manly sport
in there and they just won't seek the
help
so my dilemma is penetrating fire
departments and I know it's off topic
and I apologize for that but I was
thinking to go into Kickstarter to fund
a book that I've written about it and
then get it into a format of a teaching
format what what happens when you go
into the fire hall is it can you talk to
the fire chief who's the person yeah
that that would be part of it but the
the problem is is is it becomes like a
human resources problem a firefighter
that say gets caught with it you know in
a DUI or something like that they become
a liability to the department and so a
lot of the departments they're kind of
immediate response is to try to get rid
of them rather than helping you know
these the world people that save other
lives there their response is to just
get rid of them rather than help them so
I'm not necessarily a welcome guest this
could also be preventive them too right
it helps prevent these bad things from
happening
correct oh my gosh yeah that's my
absolute passion and desires to stop
these fire fighters from committing
suicide and so when you go fire chief
about this as a preventive measure
what's the response it really comes down
to you know I got a check with the city
attorney kind of responds you know that
they you know it's a whole cover your
but kind of situation with a lot of
these and so they're not I don't you
know and that's the problem that's why I
thought if I could fund it through you
know Kickstarter type of project I could
just launch it independently and perhaps
market it to fire unions and fire
associations and avoid the fire
departments all together yeah I mean I
love the Kickstarter idea is great for
marketing is great for promotion but it
sends your pathway and it's not the fire
choose is that the unions is it
politicians you know who is it that we
need to get to to get the fire firemen
on board with it so have you tried
talking through the city have we tried
talking to the unions I mean that I'm in
that process now so I the the thing is I
haven't haven't completed the entire
book and then struck
series that goes along with it that was
the idea of the Kickstarter was to fund
the completion of that so I could
present an entire project when I go in
and I apologize for being off-topic on
the other I didn't mean to throw a topic
I loved it I see them as two different
things a kickstarter yes go for it do it
helps you bring in some money to you
know to fund the rest of this project
that's awesome you still need to get
into the market and start talking to
these guys and get their acceptance what
might be an easy thing to do is figure
out so you don't have the whole core
simply you know that's fine you don't
have to wait for it to be completed to
go start talking to these guys let me
give you a quick example maybe this will
help
I'm an investor in a salsa dancing
company but we'll teach people how to
dance salsa & salsa is extremely
difficult and it takes a lot of time to
get there come back at the beginning
people get bored and frustrated and
freaked out and they leave so we teach
another dance that starts called
merengue which is so much easier to pick
up and dance and learn in that first
class people are having fun they love it
they enjoy themselves and then they're
keep going and learning the rest of the
dances so wondering for you you know
what is your merengue in your business
and what's the one thing you can do that
goes in that people can quickly
understand and quickly you know love it
and see results even if it may be
superficial or you know not really
getting it at the heart of the problem
but right yeah because it's a it's a
really gritty subject I guess you know
that you know it's just there's an
aversion to even acknowledging the
problem exists so well thing is to make
it easy for people to understand what
you do and the benefits one chapter in
your book or having you come in for half
a day workshop or you know you've been
available for phone calls or whatever it
is something simple and easy that people
can quickly see the benefit of so it's
easy for them to then push it upstream
and say hey we need that this program
excellent thanks Evan I appreciate the
the input no problem thanks for calling
in Tim but and for all you listening
you're trying to break into a market
where there's resistance the best thing
to do then is find your merengue find
the one thing that makes it easy for
people to understand what you do to gain
some acceptance to get them saying yes
and seeing the benefits of
you maybe even the fun so there then you
set them up to be ready for the bigger
project and of course you're over
delivering all the way through I want to
get to the call I have James on the line
which is from and how can I help
hello it's James and Dominique my
business partner yeah great we're at CLA
for the love of acting and we're a
start-up nonprofit committed to helping
the use of Los Angeles
studies have shown how vital arts
education is to developing mind so in
response to heavy pets that have been
made to arts budgets over the past
several years we created spla to serve
as a supplemental arts program to middle
and high school students teaching them
about Dramatic Arts specifically while
also taking them to plays museums
concert things like that for them to
experience different types of art forms
for its hands
our overall goal with spla is for
students to build self-confidence public
speaking skills and overall academic
achievement while we also encourage them
to pursue post-secondary education our
first question for you--even is so far
as a non-profit start a non-profit we
have sent out sponsor swampers request
letters we have made it possible people
to donate on our website at FTA charts
org we have a fundraiser with our fiscal
sponsor coming up in a week and we've
also applied for grant so with that in
mind what are some ways are there any
other innovative ways that we can try to
generate revenue for especially to start
a non-profit which you know is from what
we've heard the first couple of years
can be difficult in terms of fundraising
there's so many charities out there and
you guys a great cause I love what
you're doing thank you the biggest thing
is telling your story right like when
you're doing that you're talking about
you know one student you picked Sarah
who was a news but it really went Queen
artists and you know nobody in her
family encouraged her and she makes you
and and you turned her life around by
taking her to done her it is right like
Kelly knows
stories that's what really gets people
and involved right soon as you're coming
on I want to feel emotionally connected
to everybody's getting pitched all the
time with little charity offers and so
telling those personal stories really
tugged at the heartstrings and makes you
want to be connect this right that makes
sense I mean especially being that we we
both we're theater making us in USC so
we know how to tell stories so so going
with that's a great advice thank you so
I believe we're entrepreneurs and this
show is all about making you a success
today we are talking about over
delivering like crazy being an
invaluable resource to your customers to
your prospects to your partner's going
way beyond what the bare minimum is what
they're just asking you for so that they
love working for you and can't imagine
working with anybody else okay
another quick story this is about one of
our former radio show callers his name
is Arturo he called in a couple weeks
ago and Arturo what he does is translate
so he translates content from Spanish to
English English to Spanish and he had a
potential opportunity with a big company
and they wanted him to translate videos
so they said okay we're gonna try you
we're gonna do one video and see how you
do right they already have it translated
they knew there were mistakes and I said
Arturo come in help us fix this and this
is your trial project and he called him
he said Evan you know I want to do a
great job I don't want to just do what
they're asking I'm looking for ways that
I can make this really amazing so they
want to bring me back and hire me back
and keep coming back and so here's what
he did okay he didn't just translate the
video properly yes their mistakes that's
what they asked for
right all they wanted him to do was
translate this video properly so he did
that he did it faster than the what they
wanted right so that's that's an easy
one he did it faster than note they
wanted the gave him maybe a week and he
didn't in three days or five days or
whatever it was but he did it before
they expected it he also gave the
difference in the meaning of the
translation
so when they had the video or originally
translated there are some words that
were wrong he didn't just say here's
what's wrong he explained what that
incorrect meaning meant right and so for
a company that has you know they care
about their image they care about what
they're putting out there what kind of
content using the wrong words having a
translated incorrectly is a big deal and
so he explained what the difference was
but on top of that like even that just a
little bit beyond right and most people
can still do that but he still wanted to
go beyond you want to do more so what he
did was he looked at other videos they
had and he realized that Haiti they were
making translation mistakes and other
videos to anyone out and he fixed a
couple other videos and sent them the
transcript and then the last thing he
did was he went to their website and
they looked at errors that are on their
site it looked great in Spanish but it
didn't look so great in English they had
some mistakes and so he messaged them as
well he did all of this in less time
than what they asked they they only
asked for a translation of one video and
he did that he explained the meaning he
looked at their website found air it's
like other videos and found air and he
did all of that and less time than what
they asked for
that's over-delivering like crazy now if
they're gonna think about hmm should we
give our through the job or not what do
you think they're gonna say you want to
make it so easy for your customers to
say yes like it's a no-brainer it's it's
stupid dumb easy simple to work with you
because you're providing so much value
and that's why it's so great to start
off on one project right somebody says
we want to hire you in a test project
great that's what you want all you need
is a chance even opportunity when I'm
selling into big companies I might be
selling 50 hundred thousand
dollar-a-year contracts but when I start
off I just want one tiny little 500
dollar gig just try me out because I'm
going to blow you away I don't say that
I don't say I'm going to blow away
because the whole point is Oh
delivering right if I promise I'm gonna
over deliver then they're expecting me
to but it's easy for them to say yes to
a 500 dollar deal it's a lot harder for
them to say yes to a $50,000 $100,000
deal that's what I'm really after but
how I get there is we're taking that
small deal and an over delivering like
crazy so if you're trying to beat out a
competitor right whatever product or
service you sell people are buying from
your competition right now there's one
thing about your competition probably
that some customers they're not so happy
with maybe their software doesn't quite
do this feature maybe their service
offering doesn't quite cover this area
you're gonna take that on you do that
fine you know what keep working with
with my competitor that's great no
problem keep working with them just give
me this one little project and then blow
them away do such a good job on that one
project that they're gonna say wow we
need to give them more work and you're
gonna slowly eat away at that budget
take more more and take it away from
your competition because you're
providing such a great service to them
that's what you need to do so take on
the small projects take it on gladly
willingly that's what you want and easy
yes and then just over deliver like
crazy and blow them away here's a
difference okay here's what at the end
of the day it all comes down to it's a
difference between being a service
provider and an essential partner you
don't want to be a commodity and that's
a problem with a lot of entrepreneurs
our products our services we're a
commodity we're just a service provider
we're just somebody that a company can
or person can can hire to come in or
they just buy one product off of us
we're just a service provider if
somebody comes in and offers 10% lower
price then your customers are going to
jump to them that's what happens in a
commodity business we are just a boring
service provider the difference is when
you become an essential partner now
we're
this is where the companies that you're
working with they can't imagine doing
business without you they didn't know
what they were doing before they hired
you you've become so important to them
that they can't imagine their company
functions without you that's the love we
need to get to that's how much you need
to over-deliver that's how much you need
to wow them that's how much you need to
blow them away that you become an
essential partner in their company and
you can charge more for that now if your
price is 30% higher than your
competition they're still going to go to
you because you're that important to
them they'll gladly pay it so you need
to shift your mindset get away from
being that commodity provider from just
doing what you're asked and I'm sure you
guys do a good job but what you're asked
to do right you mow the lawns great you
go on your mother line you do what
you're asked but that's not enough in
business you need to go way above you
need to stand out you need to make me
feel important
you need to show me that you care so
there's two ways to do it okay the first
is given more the second is Surprise
them so give them more give them more
it's thinking about what they already
asked from you and just doing it better
so if the delivery time is one week you
do it overnight if they ordered 12 give
them a baker's dozen 13 did they pay
only for email support hey you know what
if they have a problem call them up or
visit them in person if there's a
problem if the only asks are certain
number of features give them everything
did they hire you only for 20 hours
spend whatever time needs to be spent to
wow them so here we're just giving them
more of what they asked for so think
about what your company can do every
step along the process what can you do
to give your clients more the second
strategy is Surprise them and surprising
them is giving them things
help their business or help them out
personally but they never asked for it
never even thought about it so here's a
few examples okay give them information
that your company might collect on
trends comments Amin supporter on their
Facebook page that they have a Facebook
page you know you have a Facebook page
how hard is that to get going and to get
comments and get engagement your
customers have the same problem so why
don't you get on there how long does it
take you to leave a few comments on
their Facebook page once a week go in
log in check it out leave some
supportive feedback do it on all their
social accounts try to refer new clients
to them it's not always going to happen
but if you think of a client that would
work well with them pass it on give them
a testimonial or a case study that they
can use in their marketing if you have a
blog or you have a website or you have a
YouTube channel interview them interview
them and give give them some exposure
say you want to write an article for
your website so you want to do an
interview with them send key contacts in
their company new articles on topics
that interest them personally one of my
best contacts of the company loves
camping and I love camping - and anytime
that I find a cool article about new
camping gear tents or barbecues whatever
it is something to take up I send it off
to her it's a way to show that I care
about her personal and it keeps our
relationship solid see if you can create
partnerships between your clients so if
you know the - - of your customers could
work well together because every
customer comes in you're talking to them
you're learning about them you're taking
a personal interest in them not just
their business so you can connect
together and help them solve a problem
that has nothing to do with you
our welcome back to the Evan Carmichael
show I believe in entrepreneurs and this
show is all about helping you be more of
a success any more clients reaching
their goals today we're talking on
over-delivering like crazy and again to
recap you need to think about being an
essential partner for your clients not
just a service provider not someone who
can be replaced
you know if somebody cuts their price by
10% they're gonna drop ship and go to
your competition and I want to share
some strategies of how I've gone and
done it and how I overdo it like crazy
to my clients okay
so I talked about giving information so
as an example I work with a lot of
entrepreneurs I have a popular website I
have the radio show got a YouTube
channel social media tons of stuff that
I do to help entrepreneurs
I collect data every month I collect
data on what's going on in the world of
entrepreneurship are people happy or
people not so happy what are their major
problems at startup or marketing or
financing whatever it is and I use that
data for my content for what I'm gonna
talk about this radio show for what I'm
gonna do on my youtube channel for what
new articles I'm gonna write and what I
do is my clients are typically big
companies big companies want to reach
out and help entrepreneurs whether
they're banks or software companies or
telecommunications companies and so what
I do is once a month collect all the
data that I use that I'm gonna use for
myself anyway and sit down with them and
share that data because they don't have
access to that data only I do and we use
it for internal purposes but I also
share it with them so there's a couple
things one it gives me face time right
the more you're in front of your
customers and your prospects and
delivering value the more they're gonna
like you know more opportunities are
going to be coming up because you're
chatting and they're going to think of
ways to work together so just having
that face time it's great too it's
giving them crazy value I'm planning my
campaigns around this data and now I'm
giving them really helpful information
that their competition doesn't have that
they can create their campaigns around
as well
I'll do a lot of experimentation with my
social media channels right with what I
post on Facebook and what I post on
YouTube and how I'm using tags and
thumbnails and all the different
strategies that I'm using to try to get
maximum exposure all of my customers
they're trying to do the same thing -
they're trying to expand their reach
they have Facebook pages and Twitter
channels and all of this stuff and so
I'll share with them here's the
experiment that I tried over the past
month and it's helped you know increase
it by 50 percent or whatever the number
is I'll share that with them but give
them the strategies that are working for
me and so this isn't something they
hired me to do they hired me to come in
and do a Twitter chat or to do one video
for them or to write a blog post this is
all way over above and beyond but it
keeps the relationship solid I like to
follow all my clients on Twitter and on
Facebook and get personally involved
what I've done is for Twitter I use a
HootSuite program so don't go to
twitter.com use HootSuite to manage
everything and it's created a separate
list just for clients and every day when
I'm having my lentils for breakfast I
load up my list and I look at all my
comments people running to me and I
respond to them and then I also look at
what my clients have posted and I try to
respond I try to either encourage them
and say great post or I'll share my
thoughts on something or if they're
running some kind of contest I'll try to
get involved somehow maybe I'll retweet
something if they're asking for
submissions I might submit something
it's helping them out
finding this this is how you're going to
stand out and be different you're a
supporter of their business you're not
just somebody that's providing them a
service this is what makes the
difference when they see your name
everybody should be happy and smiling is
that happening right now would they have
no idea who you are except the person
bought from you you want to make
yourself irreplaceable
I have a block I have a radio show I
have YouTube channel that goes out and
what I try to do is involve my clients I
need if you have an audience so I have a
sizable audience but even if you're just
getting started even if you just have a
website and you're trying to launch a
blog it's going to be your very first
post or you're trying to launch a
Facebook page make them your first post
do an interview with them show their
story this works really well when you're
selling to customers when you're selling
to business customers because they want
exposure but it can also work if you're
selling to the consumer market if you're
selling to consumers they may not want
personal exposure but they have
something that's close to their heart
maybe they're involved with a certain
charity maybe they're involved in some
kind of community work I like that
showcase it shows that you care you know
if you know that one of your customers
is running in a 5k race to charity give
them 50 bucks to support them or 25
bucks or 10 bucks whatever it is give
them something show your support because
I can guarantee you none of their other
service providers none of the other
people they buy from are doing that
that's how you stand up that's how you
get noticed that's how you make a
difference so I asked to do an interview
with them say hey I'm launching a block
and I'd love to help share your story
and why your company is great or this
cause that you're working on we talked
about sending articles right my friend
at the company now and I can call them
friends isn't the camping
and articles related to camping and
creating partnerships right you should
try to find out personal details about
everybody who comes into your company
every client you want to know something
personal about them not just what
business need do you have but something
person about them do they like baseball
are they into sushi something get some
personal information about them care
about them this is just a marketing
technique you should actually care about
your customers and when you do that
you'll find ways to connect people
you'll find commonalities between your
customers that you know that Joe can
help Susan and they don't know each
other until you introduce them and those
guys are always gonna remember you you
were the person who made that connection
happen thank you so much that's
something again that your competition is
not doing so to recap I want you guys to
over-deliver like crazy I want you to
think about ways and you can blow your
customers away give them more of what
they want Surprise them and give them
stuff that they never asked for but are
so thankful and grateful that you gave
them and think about moving away from
just being a service provider to
becoming an essential business partner
another great show thank you everybody
for calling in thank you to my producers
Daniella and Josh you guys are awesome
as usual I will be on in two more weeks
until then stay safe and believe